no one's feeling sorry for you no ladies
are feeling sorry if you've kissed a ton
of a list celebrities in your career yes
and this is the great thing about being
the best friend is you get to kiss lots
of different guys like I think that
sometimes you when you're the lead of
the movie you kiss the one guy but like
I'm always I don't know I feel like I'm
always kissing these famous people and I
don't think I come off as the type of
person that would kiss famous people but
I've managed to kiss so many and it has
been a dream of mine back a while ago I
used to have to make an actor's real
where you put on like your greatest
scenes and I wanted to make a reel of
just all the famous people I kissed
that's been a fantasy did you make that
real no sir I have not I don't know how
to use computers yes way we did we
wanted to give us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's for you yes you get to keep it
well also technology today you can grab
that anywhere yes we will take that to
the developer and we'll make up a copy
for you will have that processed in the
film Department yeah what are you
talking about can I keep it if you have
an iPhone or a computer yes you can keep
it I love that you put Lily at the
greatest that's so nice
yeah well that's yours and let's add to
the reel now I left
[Applause]
you really know how we see what my move
is right there on camera one this is my
go-to move in high school was
do you really know what lady I know what
the ladies like
you